foreign
[Music]
so this was an email we received from
Sister Sinead and I met her
it was the first meeting which took
approximately two hours
in this meeting it was very clear to me
that this sister has actually done her
research she knows a lot about
Christianity she knows about a lot about
other faiths and in fact she has done
some in-depth research about the Quran
and we had a discussion about Islam at
first and she said she is ready for the
shahada so alhamdulillah accepted Islam
she proclaimed the shahada in the
Islamic Center of Ireland and
alhamdulillah then also became very
vocal very public about her embracing of
Islam acceptance of Islam